Do we finally know where the last 2 remaining
Road Poneglyphs are that the straw hats still
need to find so they can reach laugh tale?
At the very least we have just gotten a few
major clues and a bunch of new information
dropped on our heads.
There are 3 likely locations for it: Elbaf,
an island called Vira and Beehive Island,
Blackbeards base of operation.
And, as I will explain to you, I personally
believe that Elbaf and Shanks are the most
likely candidates here.
Now you might be like: Manu, where is this
info coming from?
There is no new One Piece chapter.
Well, wrong!
Kind of.
Even though the One Piece Manga is on a four
week break at the moment, Eiichiro Oda, the
author of one piece has decided to release
a series of 4 mini booklets as a small gift
to readers in every release of SHounen Jump
instead.
This series is titled 'The Road to Laugh Tale'
and documents Oda-sensei's preparation for
the final Saga of One PIece.
The booklet contains a lot of character sketches
and recaps of things we already know.
However there are also some very chunky nuggets
of fresh information and reveals to be found
as well.
This first volume is focused very heavily
on Roger and how he became pirate king, dedicating
a whole page to the mysterious Poneglyphs.
And by far the biggest thing in this I think,
is that Oda discusses the locations of the
four road poneglyphs here.
We of course already know of 2 that the straw
hats have in their possession: The one from
Zou and one form Big Mom, that Brook heroically
made a successful rubbing off, similar to
how Roger got his hands on it.
The third poneglyph Roger found in Wano itself
and the last one was located in Fishman island,
where it stood right next to Joyboys apology
letter to the mermaid princess.
Now funnily enough, we didn't actually know
for a fact whether the third road poneglyph
was still in wano.
All we have seen so far are two of the 30+
rio poneglyphs that detail the history of
the void century.
However, this booklet tells us, that Kaido's
rule over a closed border Wano has kept anyone
else from getting their hands on his road
poneglyph.
Which is huge in a number of ways.
Because I think it's basically the first time
we officially get confirmed that it's still
waiting here in wano for the straw hats to
find.
That means that the straw hats will get their
hands on it.
It also means we still have another story
thread that needs to happen in Wano, which
makes me happy, because I didn't want to leave
the country as quickly as the last few chapters
made it seem.
However, it also means, that other people
might now come for that very same road poneglyph.
Im thinking of course Blackbeard, and for
some reason now also Buggy.
Luffy's two main rivals to becoming pirate
king.
Because Blackbeard surely would have been
aware of Kaido sitting on top of that particular
red stone.
It also might be the reason or at least one
of the reasons why Momo decided to leave Wano's
borders closed for now until Luffy reaches
Laugh Tale, telling Zuneshia, 'thanks for
dropping by, but actually could you come back
another time?'
The fact that a road poneglyph is located
in wano also adds a lot more weight to the
reveal that Oden's father and Momo's grandfather,
Kozuki Sukiyaki, former Shogun of Wano and
heir of the Kozuki clan is still alive.
I somehow totally overlooked that in the last
chapter, but he was obviously the one who
taught Oden how to read and write the language
of the ancient kingdom.
In other words, Oda just snuck another character
back into the story that can potentially lead
the way to the final island.
This is HUGE.
Sukiyaki might be the lottery ticket someone
like Blackbeard has been waiting for to make
his way to Laugh tale as well, should he not
get his hands on Robin.
Him and Robin are pretty much the only two
confirmed people alive who can do this.
And should Blackbeard make his way to wano
to get this poneglyph and find out who SUkiyaki
is, that would be a true advantage falling
into his hands.
But as if this wasn't enough, Oda-sensei also
decided to tease us with the location of last
remaining, lost road poneglyph that used to
be on Fishman island.
And he gives us 3 possible locations: Elbaf,
Beehive island itself and Vira.
You might now be asking what the Usopp is
a Vira.
It's actually an island that was named by
Nami once, very early on in the story as she's
reading Noland's journnal.
In other words, it's an island that was visited
by Noland 400 years ago and was described
as a very lively and happy place.
Since then, this small town expanded into
a full-blown country, but it was no longer
a happy place to live.
Instead it was ruled by a tyrannical government
associated with the world nobles.
After the breakout of a rebellion, it was
finally freed by the revolutionary army.
Oda-sensei of course mentions that there are
other possibilities for the location, as he
should, but he still chose to focus on these
three specifically.
And I think it makes sense, because all 3
of these islands seem to have ties to powerful
people who might have gotten their hands on
the last poneglyph.
Vira is connected to the Revolutionaries and
Dragon, who clearly know quite a lot about
the true history, which was why Robin in particular
got send to them by Kuma.
Maybe it's the island the revolutionaries
moved their operations to, after they got
raided by Bladckbeards crew on their old base.
And who knows, maybe blackbeard came for them
exactly because he knew that they had a road
poneglyph.
Which of course brings us to Beehive island.
It used to be the base for Rocks D Xebec,
who also has a page dedicated to him in this
booklet, that details his connections to Blackbeard,
who also named his ship the Xebec.
Now it's Blackbeards home and since Blackbeard
is also aiming to become pirate king, it would
make sense for him to already have his hands
on a poneglyph there as well.
Lastly, there is Elbaf.
Not only has elbaf been hinted at over and
over again to be the next island the straw
hats will travel to after wano, as I've discussed
in previous videos, you have Usopps relationship
to the giants, Big mom's relationship to the
giants, the introduction of Loki, and so on.
But it also seems like Elbaf has strong ties
to another Yonko.
Shanks.
As I explained in his character analysis,
Shanks has a very strong viking theme going
on.
There is of course his ship, that has the
same style as Sorry and Broggy's, but Shanks
is also inspired by the Nordic God Tyr, who
also lost an arm to a beast and a number of
other parallels.
We also know that the Yonko, including Shanks
hold territory.
Again something that is discussed in the Road
to Laugh Tale.
Territorial dispute in the new world between
the Yonko and co.
And so I have always been a strong supporter
of the idea that Elbaf is part of Shank's
territory.
His home turf in the new world if you like.
A man with a bounty of over 4B berries.
I have 61 Million berries, 100 for each subscriber.
Ouch.
But we're not trying to beat Shanks, we're
trying to beat Trebol, who has 99M for the
magical 100M berries, in other words 1M subscribers.
So not only can you make that dream come true
by subscribing, but you also get freshly harvested
one piece content, every single week.
And I think it would truly make sense for
the man who is making sure to carry on Roger's
will as a Yonko, to grab the most easily accessible
road poneglyph from Fishman island and protect
it for only the right person to see.
The man Roger was waiting for.
In other words Luffy.
Shanks definitely knew about the Road poneglyph
there, he traveled to fishman island with
Roger.
Elbaf is a true fortress of an island, just
like Wano, filled with some of the most powerful
warriors in the entire world.
So really what better place to have the final
road potnglyph hidden, than the next location
the straw hats are heading to.
A place where luffy can finally meet shanks.
A place where he has to earn his right to
the last red stone and proof his worth as
a YOnko.
And also a place, where finally Shanks and
Blackbeard face each other once again, as
Blackbeard would surely come for that very
same poneglyph as well.
And if you really want to know what has been
foreshadowed about Elbaf and how the arc might
play out in the end and why Shanks has such
strong ties to nordic mythology, you should
not miss out on these two videos right here.